the search for one-dimensional very
simple correlations one drug one
clinical effect in all patient is
horrendously obstacle hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with reason TV and today we're
talking with peter huber he's the author
most recently of the cure in the code
how 20th century law is undermining 21st
century medicine Peter thanks for
talking to us my pleasure let's talk
about the advent of kind of molecular
level medicine and the ways of which
kind of existing regulatory apparatus is
get in the way of that talk about the
intense personalization of medical kind
of technology that you're advocating in
the book well to begin with molecular
medicine has been here as long as people
have been trying to have drugs I mean
drugs are operate down at the molecular
level their molecules interacting with
other molecules I'm until very recently
it was treated as as a science of one
hand clapping he could control the the
drugs chemistry but nobody could probe
in any depth what was going on in the
patients in a particular individual what
right in one way or many I mean we just
couldn't see what was going on down
there we we were lucky if we even saw
microbes until quite recently and
viruses were even more difficult you
know in our in our generation we've
acquired the ability to see everything
down there and that transforms molecular
medicine beyond recognition it means you
can design drugs to treat molecules with
and what they do and I mean what you're
calling for it I mean in a lot of ways
you know the span of the past several
centuries has been towards more
individualized understanding of people
of knowledge ha's of societies I mean
you're talking about using genomics and
other things so that we can actually
match a drug with a particular patient
yeah this is not a policy question I
mean the science of drugs is molecules
interact with other molecules you just
can't escape but that's where the
science really happens okay this is I'm
not the first to recognize this until
very recently we couldn't do that
science properly okay and so we build up
this big apparatus that uses surrogates
says well let's throw the drug at a
person and if they somehow recover and
their clinical symptoms change which are
way up here not down at the molecular
level will say the drug is good and
if it doesn't work consistently well out
with the drug it turns out that there's
a lot of diverse chemistry down there
your body is not quite the same as mine
and your disease even if it has the same
clinical symptoms may be quite
significantly different from what is
superficially the same one in my bar
before we get to the regulatory
structure how far along are we in terms
of pharmaceutical companies being able
to really say okay they're looking at
your your molecular chemistry and here
is how we're going to tweak a particular
drug to work most effectively on you
well a very substantial fraction of the
pipelines out there today it's probably
somewhere between thirty and fifty
percent are now genomic in some respect
or other so what we're where the real
choke points in the process of
developing this how much of it is on the
kind of medical establishment side how
much of it is on the regulatory side and
how much of it is that patients either
don't understand this or kind of worried
about this type of experimentation well
let's start with the part that we've
become astonishingly good at and I think
many people don't realize is we are very
good at designing targeted drugs now we
have two very good technologies for
doing that one is called structure based
design which is basically what it sounds
like you get a very good biochemist or
increasingly a very good supercomputer
you show them the molecular target may
be taken from a cancer cell or an HIV
viral particle and you say whack this
and and they can they can build a
molecule that'll do that if they meet
one-on-one but it's getting the drug
from here to that point in your body
lots of things can happen livers can
metabolize that your immune system can
go haywire your kidney can be poisoned
and so you've got a multi-dimensional
problem from the get-go and it used to
be assumed you know in fact you'll find
a lot in the literature all our bodies
are ninety-nine point nine percent the
same or something like that genetically
speaking that is ancient history that
kind of teaching that they've been
looking at smaller and smaller
variations in our genes there's a
tremendous amount of genetic diversity
underneath us and that of course frames
how the disease's progress and whether
how drugs work and so then I mean so
there are immense technical difficulties
in terms of really getting this stuff
right that the the big challenge is now
basically reverse engineering
my body's it is a it is understanding
the complex biology of cancers and your
neurological diseases and so on we are
developing an enormous amount of durable
capital here as we and the way you work
that out are certainly one way is to
gather a whole lot of molecular data and
clinical data and put it in huge
databases and then unleash the the
people who are very good at this which
are the digerati they you know Google
and Microsoft do this all the time
looking for patterns and very complex
data but now it's I mean talk a little
bit about the regulatory restrictions
that are keeping this from happening
because online you know when we're
talking about data it seems you know
it's easier to do than when your weddin
Lee when you're talking about medicine
Wow to start with it the analytical that
the computational tools we've got them
now okay we can do those calculations
for very complex systems Andy Grove
actually wrote a little Abed in science
a couple of years ago saying we can do
it we've got to get beyond and this gets
to the other part of your question what
he calls the FDA's tyranny of the
averages okay Washington cannot handle
this complexity the FDA has archaic and
and inadequate IT systems okay they
still entered data manually in some
instances their offices don't talk to
each other and they just don't have this
kind of expertise you find that at
Google and among people who do big data
all the time we've got those tools the
FDA is still very much locked into the
old model saying when to validate a drug
we want to see the drug prescribed in
the standard way and we want to see you
know predictably producing a desired
clinical effect okay so talk talk a
little bit about the ways around that
because this this is a gigantic clash
and it's really you know the clash is
happening over the human body which is
wasting away from various diseases and
disorders you talked a bit about how in
the I guess in the 80s and 90s activists
HIV activists we're able to kind of jump
start a route around FDA typical FDA
approval processes is that the best
model for kind of changing the
regulatory structure it was very good in
its time okay the gay community had a
tremendous impact for a while okay until
the drugs arrived
and then the FDA began to back off but
basically it comes down to this this the
search for one dimensional very simple
correlations one drug one clinical
effect in all patient is horrendously
obviously that is bad that is that is
basically that kind of averaging I think
you can put this it's not too strong to
say if you demand drugs perform that way
we will not cure many of the serious
diseases we're now facing because they
aren't single you know one cause one
effect one drug diseases they just don't
work that way you're asking for the
biochemically impossible the FDA still
generally requires that is norm is that
because the FDA is willfully ignorant or
is it I mean it's at an institutional
thing like what how do we how do we r at
around the FDA then well treated as a
virus that we Wow well that's that's a
more political question that it look in
the 1990s the disease was so frightening
it was killing so many young and
sympathetic victims you know
notwithstanding all the talk about there
being discrimination and bigotry there
was plenty of that too but I'll tell you
there was a consensus that spanned the
end of the Reagan administration Bush
won and most of to Clinton terms that
said we just got to get these drugs out
and the FDA itself wrote a bunch of
rules that actually you know carved fast
tracked our accelerated approval tunnels
through it through its own regulations
they had the benefit of something called
the Orphan Drug Act enacted in 1984 that
allowed them very flexible licensing
there was a lot of off-label use of
drugs and I mean they started down
exactly the right path and I'll tell you
if they had said gee this is working and
formalized it and updated it as we got
better more targeted drugs and better
analytical tools we would be a decade or
two ahead of where we are today on
during some a lot of intractable
diseases and in one way the the best
hope to jump starting or pushing ahead
with us actually to give more
information to individuals as opposed to
government authorities or even
pharmaceutical companies you know the
fact i actually think there's a First
Amendment problem when the FDA walks out
and says hey you know he'll be you're
not allowed to read your own genome and
at least not by a company who's giving
you unapproved statements about what
that genome implies the FDA doesn't know
what implies either so I don't see and I
don't see why I should have to wait for
them to say this is the correct
interpretation of that date I don't
think I think frankly there's a case
headed for the Supreme Court on that 1i
I don't think people have fought the
other issue you know can they regulate
drugs we're not going to win that in the
Supreme Court but I right to read our
bodies yes I think we will that's
probably the most novel interpretation
of the First Amendment that I'll here
all week it sounds not not yet a novel
without the right to read you know is
guaranteed as you're not really isn't
and since when when did we lose our
right to read our own innards you know I
mean that's great well we'll leave it
there thank you so much peter huber
author most recently of the Cure in the
code how 20th century law is under
binding 21st century medicine thanks so
much for talking to reason TV I'm
Nicholas